so today's draft who benefits the most
from a conference championship win this
weekend we will each make three picks
big cat you get the trivia question if
you get it right you get the first pick
if you get it wrong Sims gets the first
pick Derrick Henry won the rushing title
this year with 1540 yards there are only
three other players in NFL history that
have won the rushing title and got to
the Super Bowl in the same year
named one of them Emmitt Smith yes yes
right what color is the color blue that
was that that's that's I'm disappointed
in you jeez okay so I have to be
strategic here because it is a three way
draft right wait so we know the other
ones Terrell Davis in 1998 yep and Shaun
Alexander in 2005 but Emmitt Smith did
it three times 92 93 95 all right go
ahead okay all right so I have to be
strategic here and I don't want Chris
Sims to be able to wax poetic ly about
Aaron Rodgers so I will take care of
number one and remind everyone the so
called goat by Chris Sims has won Super
Bowl victory to his name and he would
benefit the most because I think that if
you want to be one of the greatest of
all time he needs to probably get
another Lombardi Trophy into that trophy
case so he would benefit the most and
then you throw in the the additional
Mike McCarthy Aaron Rodgers thing that
ended poorly last year can he now make
the argument that they might have been
in more Super Bowls if it weren't for
Mike McCarthy he probably can if they
get there with Matt Lafleur in his first
year so I would say Aaron Rodgers
benefits the most by winning on Sunday
and going to another Super Bowl and
maybe getting that second Lombardi
Trophy that would then then cement him
as one of the greatest of all time yeah
no he's already one of the greatest of
all time we just saw the other hundred
year all-time team Dan Marino was one of
the quarterbacks who didn't win a Super
Bowl one of the greatest of all time
it's not it's a team sport okay but
Rodgers wasn't alright I know well it's
okay there was a lot of modern day
quarterbacks no more
there was only two that really made it
so that's all good but up yours big cat
okay so either way Andy Reed will be my
pick nice strategic there by you big cat
but I got to go with Andy Reed of course
yes I mean he's he's famous for not
getting they're not getting it done the
greatest coach we've ever seen to not
win a Super Bowl and he's only been
there once and he's had the conference
championship you know mishaps and of
course last year at home against the the
Patriots and you know big cat I already
mentioned it came out stale early and
then they bounce back and find a way but
he's the guy that I think benefits the
most to have that opportunity to finally
win that Super Bowl and to maybe correct
this championship game bad record stigma
that he has as well I think he would
benefit the most by winning on Sunday
yeah I agree with you guys on both of
the first two picks but the next obvious
one for me is Patrick my home's the
chief quarterback it's his second year
as a starter he had the AFC championship
game at home last year and lost it it's
almost that not that he benefits it's
that he avoids slipping into this
narrative where he can't win the AFC
Championship game at home but also
getting to the Super Bowl in his second
year as a starter I think is important
because it's going to further this
notion that this guy really is
revolutionising the game this guy is
gonna be a guy who has multiple Super
Bowl wins by the time it's said and done
multiple MVP awards and it is kind of
strange how Lamar Jackson came out of
nowhere this year to get us not thinking
about Patrick mahomes well we're
thinking about Patrick mahomes a lot and
we're gonna be thinking about him even
more if and when and I say when they
went on Sunday all right you get half
credit Mike because the real true point
behind Patrick mahomes benefiting the
most from a victory on Sunday is the
fact that Patrick mahomes is about to
get paid a lot a lot a lot of money he's
getting it either way it doesn't know
everyone why he's still get Mike Mike
let me finish because I'm about to make
your point better than you did Patrick
mahomes
when he gets that a lot a lot a lot of
money the roster construction is going
to change he might be on the best team
that he will be on
for the rest of his career because you
can't pay everyone so when he gets paid
and he now they can't have you know guys
running everywhere down the field he
might in five six years be like hey
where all my weapons oh I had all the
weapons when we could pay everyone we
can't pay everyone anymore so that's why
it's important that he gets the Super
Bowl here with this team
so Mike again I should get credit for
your pick because I made it better
actually you know what that would just
be my pick patch my home's and then just
put in parentheses big cat made a better
point the laziest thing that is ever
have to live Draft all right go ahead
I like it I like it that's really good
you guys are like a dysfunctional couple
I don't even know what to say with you
two I'm gonna go with my buddy Kyle
Shanahan I think he'd been talked to the
most well Jack I don't think you can
disagree with this one you know hey you
know Kyle Shanahan gets this huge
contract you know six years guaranteed
all of that didn't go the best the first
two years finally make a trade for Jimmy
Garoppolo he got her last year your two
was underwhelming I mean this year and
going to a Super Bowl would absolutely
just verify that Kyle Shanahan was the
right guy to be the head coach of the
San Francisco 49ers let alone the
historical you know what do I want to
say legacy type thing here I mean
Shanahan would be the first father-son
duo to ever go to the Super Bowl as head
coaches that's pretty amazing too I mean
that's a legacy in itself so to me
that's the more of the big reason why I
take Kyle over some of these other guys
it's just because man to say you go to
the Super Bowl to verify you're the
being the head coach but then your
father who want it twice and now you're
in a Super Bowl as well that kind of
puts you in a very upper upper
stratosphere of like football lineage
big names hierarchy I'll see you
Scioscia to your tattoo gets like the
value of your tattoo goes up thank you
yes you're right yeah it's very
important will you add to the tattoo
where you add the last name so people
know that KS means Kyle Shanahan on some
other KSU
doing anything like that nothing like
that okay you know there's things you do
in college they're not always the
smartest things but I'm still proud of
my tattoo all right it was an important
time they were great friends of mine and
yeah there's still some days I look down
there go man what the hell was I
thinking with that and when you say he's
the right guy for the 49ers I mean it's
the right guy in the appropriate way not
the Cleveland Browns right guy every
other year yeah all right the next guy
for me is Ryan Tannehill the Titans
quarterback and this is closer to the
point that big cat was making about
Patrick mahomes although it's more about
Ryan Tannehill 'z ship finally coming in
this is a guy who's due to become a free
agent the Titans are they're gonna have
to franchise tag this guy at 26 27
million which is more than anybody ever
thought he would make next year or they
gonna have to let him hit the open
market either way if he gets to a Super
Bowl his value goes through the roof
even if you don't have a lot to do with
it because he led the NFL in passer
rating this year at 1 17.5 it was the
4th highest ever for a single season and
the Titans aren't winning this game
without Ryan Tannehill making a throw
that would be at the top of the
highlight reel for when it's time to get
Ryan Tannehill paid or to get the Titans
to use the franchise tag or to give him
a long-term contract out from under the
franchise tag he's gonna have to do
something at some point on Sunday that
you can point to and say this is your
guy if the Titans are going to advance
ok bad pick Mike I have the best pick
that is going to end this Draft it's
Derrick Henry
you mentioned Terrell Davis earlier
guess what
Terrell Davis not a long career won a
couple Super Bowls was had that
unbelievable stretch where he was
out-of-this-world good Derrick Henry is
in the middle of an unbelievable stretch
where he's out-of-this-world good if he
can win a Super Bowl this year and he
puts up numbers this week and ensue in
the Super Bowl game he might already
have a case for a Hall of Fame career if
he adds a couple more years on top of it
because that's what that is that the
trail Davis argument right a short
career but he was the greatest for a
small period of time and he was
electrifying and he won a Super Bowl
Derrick Henry might have that same case
if he can finish off the
run and they win a Super Bowl a lot at
stake for him he benefits a lot from it
yeah you're right he does he can kind of
put himself into you know a class of
running backs we just mentioned I think
he's gonna need a lot more I got a look
at the all-time rushing list but I think
he's still gonna need right he is
Terrell Davis played seven years Mike
okay he played seven seasons yeah he's
gonna play seven seasons yeah no he is
and you know I do think that this you
know puts you in there pretty if he gets
the ball let's be clear on this okay
Derrick Henry is currently tied with the
great John Arnett for 220 ninth place on
the all-time rushing list with 3833
yards let's not forget Derrick Henry
took like four years to get to this
point well you don't know whether this
is like something's gonna continue or
whether it's the aberration might not
have he did not play like this his first
few seasons Mike how long can he do it
physically Mike if he gets off if he
goes 180 yards they win on Sunday if he
goes 180 yards they win the Superbowl
and then you just said at 3,000 3,500
yards all he needs is for more seasons
to get total yardage the the Trail Davis
head they'd have very similar resumes
after that so another great point by me
sorry Chris going up no all good all
good they were all great points I mean I
always enjoy you crapping all over
Floria so don't worry you're always
welcome to talk I'm gonna go I still
think he's got a long way to go I'm
still got a long way to go and he's got
to physically hold up hey shut up I
gotta go I'm gonna go the hunt family
the owners of the Kansas City Chiefs
okay I mean when's the last time they
were at a Superbowl Mike I mean was that
when they beat your Minnesota Vikings
when you were just a little boy and
shattering dreams right that was the
last I wasn't I wasn't a football fan
then I was for years okay well either
way your team lost it was a precursor to
what was gonna happen and I mean they
are the AFC a lot of ways when you think
about the Kansas City Chiefs of course
we're in the first Super Bowl against
the Green Bay Packers it's been since
nineteen what was that 70 I believe
since they've been to the Super Bowl so
this would really benefit a family who's
got great heritage and history in the
NFL so important to what we have is an
NFL right now and for them to get back
I'm gonna go with a Clark cut I mean the
AFC championship trophy there for a
while was that what does it call guys
it's the Lamar Hunt trophy really cool
have that stupid thing that looks like
an oversized monopoly thing but yes
Clark on that's the guy I'm looking at
that's gonna really benefit from this
justifying all the moves he made to get
Andy Reed in Kansas City and everything
like that I'm surprised this guy's still
available Matt Lafleur yeah I'm talking
about the first year head coach of the
Green Bay Packers he came in there
facing all sorts of potential
complications and adversity he got a
quarterback he got a tiptoe around you
have a team that is perceived to have a
high degree of talent it's one of the
most storied franchises in the NFL who's
Matt Lafleur he's a guy who bumped into
the into Sean mcvade in the hallway once
I mean and and here we are 14 and three
one game away from a Super Bowl
appearance in his first season as a head
coach and if they win it all right every
time a guy wins the Super Bowl in Green
Bay the name is Street after this guy's
gonna have a street named after him
after one year potentially who are the
coaches history wise that have gone to
the Super Bowl after one year I know
Barry Switzer and George Seifert did it
right but they took over like no no in
his second year you're right right so
Seifert imhad who else jim caldwell took
the cult's to the Super Bowl in his
first year after Tony Dungy right
retired right and yes Seifert but you
know I mean any of us could have coached
the 49ers at that point would have won
the Super Bowl so fer Lafleur to do what
he did with a team that was out of the
playoffs for two years this was not a
team that was built to go to well who
would have dreamed that how many people
had the Packers on their Super Bowl
prediction list back in in September so
I think it's a huge accomplishment from
out LeFleur just to be here but to take
it to the next level in his first year
as coach of the Packers to get there and
I think it means a lot for him I win no
big better point you guys you guys have
the same pick and round to it so you
don't beat me all right there they all
are if you're watching on TV we will
spare the radio crowd the recap you were
paying attention you heard all the pig
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports